oh I'm playing another uh notable player
I don't think I played fobby in title
Tuesday
it's so funny because
I was on this podcast recently
and he he mentioned something about some
opening he's going to play in title
Tuesday but okay we're not going into
exactly that
okay let me calm down
oh that's kind of hard it's gonna be
very hard to get my heart rate below 100
this game
yeah the basic idea is to do this stuff
uh Bishop H6 maybe can be played right
away but
okay going for this
so yeah B4 92 Queen A5 King B1
this is all pretty standard and E5 might
be played
Bishop E6 with their own mate and then
Knight C1 defense
I'm actually surprised he's going into
this because
this is already considered to be
decent for white
sure I've had this position before
[Music]
like those simple plans to checkmate
life calls
uh
maybe G4 makes sense
or maybe versus
[Music]
can I see one
yeah so Knight H5 92
another simple idea is just to take the
bishop in page five
okay here I think I have to take
unless I go like Full Throttle
which is actually kind of interesting
like G4 here
and G4 c5h5
um
that prevents the queen from helping
defend
it's a risk but
might as well take it
okay now I can take and take on D4
uh then Queen E5
Queen E5 I just Retreat oh no Queenie
five I take the pawn
yeah something in this Android in G5
really in G5 F4 oh he wants to play C5
wow
with C5 I take
also C5 yeah I just take with check
F4 that's why I can't play
if I take that doesn't work either
in 92 preparing us for
C5 just Queen E3
an idea to play Queen E3 Knight F4
allowing Knight C4 man
and let's see four queen of two
maybe it's okay
there's some weird like Knight T2 ideas
combination with B3
not sure how strong they are
wow what is this
what's the point
wow
F6
that's terrifying
of a piece
oh no oh Rook C2 of 0.83
Bishop H3 on the horizon
foreign
am I losing though
What's Happening Here
oh no my time
oh I have a draw
I know what's happening here I think I I
just had repetition I had to play Queen
d8 though
oh what a game
oh
at least we gotta break it now
I really need a break this is like the
highest my heart rate has ever been
yeah for Moon I thought C2 but
miraculously I have takes in Queen F6
and maybe they even have it
I had in this position takes
yeah had my chance
okay let's see how much was missed
in this game
yeah I got a little bit too low on time
I think the final position should be a
draw
yeah I mean I was about to play Queen E8
I think
the quindi is a draw
and then earlier
I missed Knight H5
oh 95 is losing though for whites
ah because King f8 wow
yeah this is a deadly mating attack
oh then it's winning for me wait how's
this winning
I just have to not get mated so Bishop
five
it's still really tricky though rookie
one threatening Queen B2 mate
and then Queen
so Queen has to defend
yeah it's still not easy to win this
oh Fabiano had made in seven here Queen
A3
leaving the black Rook sandwiched
between the right white Rooks but
threatening this
and threatening to uh take on C1
and then I just have nothing
okay so black was winning
but earlier yeah earlier things were
under control
although it was Knight B2 oh Knight B2
is the best move
and it was absolutely terrifying but
black had to play B3 here
I mean C3 looked super reasonable though
to prepare this
and also unleash the bishop
but I was happy to find this and like
worst case scenario I could potentially
sock on C3
but that wasn't needed
yeah what a game okay this will be nice
YouTube content
I mean
often I post like the full title of
Tuesdays to YouTube
but uh
I might have to make YouTube videos out
of these single games
because the game before this was against
Eric Hanson
which uh
was also super intense